Friday I did like a 3-hour interview
with this woman from CBS Sunday morning
okay and the map was out of his [ __ ]
mind I didn't know any of this what
happened what do you mean ma'amed heard
that CBS Sunday morning was gonna turn
their cameras on the writing room he
freaked out he didn't look good enough
he started to put ice bags on his eyes
like there's 30 guys in there he thought
this was his segment it was highly
exaggerated but look some days you just
wake up and you look like [ __ ] yeah and
what did you think the CBS cameras we're
gonna be just on you or something
well thank you many cameras were gonna
be going around so I didn't want to look
like complete [ __ ] right
and I was had ice in one hand I was
working with the other hand I wasn't
just sitting back everybody froze up no
nobody was doing it they were like hey
guys and they're like hey guys I go hey
Howard a how you doing like maybe we
should have even worked out like they
needed a rehearsal it's the new cameras
because if I had said something nice
about you I would have got in trouble
for like kissing yeah would have been
nice I know Howard you know you know
I've been working here since I got out
of college ya know and I'm a vet and how
it helps veterans maybe that would've
been good anything makes me look good
it was super like hey these are some of
the most talented people in the world
let's go say hi to him think I walk in
there like you knew they were gonna be
doing CBS Sunday morning I didn't know
that give me like a couple days heads up
maybe you're right you know I don't
think of something to say
I'm getting a consensus from the office
well that's kind of downplaying if they
said he was pretty wound up about
looking good yeah I wanted to look good
but I was only icing with one eye and I
got to tell you the way you guys were
like stone-cold robots you ain't gonna
be on camera you don't have to worry you
woulda thought I don't even know any of
them okay here's my staff there's like
crickets cuz every time you see a like a
documentary or a news piece about you
know a late night show or they go into
the writers room and everyone's just
tossing around
oh yeah they're goofing around we were
just like uh the reporter Tracy Smith
said gee my stapler has more of a
personality than your riding rope yeah
all right
this is your funny these guys are a
barrel of laughs